[Music]
[Applause]
that's never happened we've done
episodes never a PD chance thanks
everybody
weird question anyone here name's Eric
anybody's parents just not gonna round
with names Zarek I think we found a
winner he's getting best audience
members Eric right there yeah thank you
so this is too fun I was recently at a
wedding I love weddings but you know
what was weird about this wedding
no one was dancing does that suck is
there anything sadder than an empty
dance floor at a wedding you see it you
see potential for fun but you're like
tumbleweed blowing through it cowboy
like yeah yeah people used to have fun
here till that damn Mambo number five
tragedy of 99 toothpicks cigarette straw
your choice but then just wouldn't look
like that wedding was about to flatline
this is true one brave soul not me I
wish it were made one brave soul rose
above the rest
went over to the DJ made a request and
started dancing with himself in the
center of the floor dancing with himself
to Billy Idol's dancing with myself this
is true the whole song it's like over
four minutes you guys he's straight-up
got down to the entire song it was great
another song might have been sad you
know just one man got out there to dance
triumphantly to Alanis Morissette
[Laughter]
nobody wants to see that we all know the
agathi etre part but the Billy Idol guy
not only wasn't sad he got the party
started and listen to me that is the
best gift you can give a bride and groom
making the party they're throwing for
their love a good time I'm not saying
like donut you don't have to lace the
cake with psychedelics you're like I
love you trash is it no is it just me or
is this cake also eating me what I'm
saying is if you're invited to a wedding
it's your job to make sure that's a
great wedding don't leave it up to the
DJ DJ there's only so much he can do
with his ponytail always a ponytail
trying to raise the roof from behind a
laptop just like all right folks we're
here to get on up party on down then
write it right across the middle for
Diane and Sam let's get it going nothing
don't let it be nothing that is your cue
get up there and request the song that
gets any party started you know the song
Montell Jordan song this is how we do it
you know because that's always the song
it comes on and even the minister drops
the fork
[Applause]
look I know I'm a self-conscious person
but until Jordans bossy why are you
having so much record sales but listen I
know that dancing at a wedding can be
embarrassing it's hard sometimes you're
surrounded by strangers people you don't
know
crayons children judgmental caterers but
that's why it's your gift you're
sacrificing your dignity for the good of
the marriage and for anybody that's just
too self-conscious to start dancing
here's the solution pull up a girl grab
a girl they love that grab a girl by the
hand spin her out there someone's just
waiting for someone to make a move he'll
pull an old woman up out of her chair
chill look make sure it's not a wheel
chair you got to make sure that chair
does not have wheels or this whole thing
does not work you give me like
and listen to this too if you're in one
of those weddings where they invite
anyone to give a toast give a toast
they're waiting for someone to give a
toast but who won't be good they're not
supposed to be good just don't let there
be a mic up there just like anybody
anybody Ty and Sam nothing okay
figure it out by the time you get up to
the mic he'll have something to say just
be like coz Diane Sam I just want to say
you know making your way in the world
today takes everything you've got taking
a break from all your worries sure would
help a lot wouldn't you like to get away
Cheers
[Applause]
[Music]